♪ ♪ ♪
- Nous sommes au Russian Samovar
en plein coeur de Manhattan.
♪ ♪♪♪♪
Une institution, depuis 1986, ùu
se retrouvent exilés russes,
ukrainiens, ouzbek quand ils ont
le mal du pays.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais depuis la guerre,
le restaurant a vu son chiffre
d'affaires chuteaiaiais
les affaires reprennent
tranquillement
"Quand la guerre a commencé,
nos affaires ont chuté de
60 à 70%. On a perdu beaucoup de
clients, sans compter
le harcèlement qu'itititit
depuis le 24 février.
"Ls s s s donnaient des coups de
pied sur la porte", dit-il.
"On reçoit toujours des messages
de haine. On nous traite de
fascistes et de nazis, alors
esesesest Juifs."
Depuis, ils arborent le drapeau
ukrainien et multiplient
les levées de fonds pour
les réfugiés.
En face, le Russian vodka room.
"On a changé la vodka russe pour
de la vodka canadienne", dit-il.
Nikolai est le gérant, et lui
aussi s'est fait harceler
"Je parlais russe  a a a a ami,
dit-il. On me demandait pourquoi
je suis ici, d'arrêter la
guerre, le ton était agressif."
"J'ai quitté la Russie, parce
que c'est dangereux d'être gay,
dit-il. On n'a rien à voir avec
cette guerre."
On appelle ce coin de New York
Little Odessa. C'est à Brighton
Beach, à une heure de Manhattan.
Katia est venue profiter du beau
temps avec sa mère, qui est
arrivée du Bélarus il y a un an.
"On s'entretue, dit-elle.
On a de la parenté dans toute
l'Europe de l'Est. On a de
la famille en Ukraine.
Et impossible d'envoyer de
l'argent au Bélarus, pour aider
sa famille."tetetetetetern Unioé
son service, dit-elle.
On ne peut rien envoyer.
La situation va se détériorer."
La station Freedom FM estlalal,
à New York et Miami.
"Je suis déprimé, choqué.
J'ai honaeaeaeaeaeaeael
Novakoff. Je me sens mal pour
les Ukrainiens et les Russes.
Ce n'est pas le peuple
qui a commencé la guerre,
c'"""""""
"Et cette guerre aurait pu être
évitée, dit Michael Lévitis.
Il y a actuellement des
pourparlers de paix, dit-il,
que l'Ukraine soit neutre,
démilitarisée, et qu'elle ne
fasse pas partie de l'OTAN.
Ce sont les mêmes demandes
qu'avant la guerre. Et Zelensky
considère cette possibilité."
Même les enfants ont leur point
de vue.
"Cette guerre n'ddddddddû
se produire."
Moitié Russe et Ukrainien,
il incarne, peut-être à lui
tout seul, l'espoir de ce peuple
déchiré.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, New Yor